we also have like major problems in
Idaho in well in the west because if you
look at a map and people out east just
don't realize this but if you look at a
map east of the Colorado Rockies the
federal government controls 51 percent
of the the land mass and in Idaho it's
61 percent and then they're controlling
72 percent of the subsurface mineral
rights wow and so it's making it so like
Idaho can't even pay its own bills like
we're beholden to the federal government
to pay our bills because they're
controlling all our land and our
resources and so that that battle has to
be fought and I plan on fighting how did
the feds get control of the land so it's
a long long story but this is like the
whole battle that my family was in you
know that that basically culminated in
2014 because the states were enabled
into the union and and all the land and
all the resources were supposed to then
go to the state and the jurisdiction of
the of that state but
through this environmentalist movement
and because the air the area is so arid
people didn't go live on it they
couldn't live on it and the federal
government came in later and claimed it
and now they're claiming it as their own
they're saying it's in trust
um and that they never they never uh
they never released it or or disposed of
it is the right word and so there's this
major battle with like families like my
my father my family and my father in
particular where they're trying to
defend their rights and my family my
family's been there for now almost 150
years and the federal government comes
in and says well we're taking it from
you well there's this and that's
happening all over the west and well I
mean but you got to trust the government
right they're they're here sure sure
yeah they're here to help and they're
doing it for you know the right reason
I'm sure you know uh what was it the
tortoise yeah desert tortoise but it
well you gotta protect the tortoise well
yeah yeah what is your family for all
tortoise that's that's right yeah I mean
I mean that's probably why my family
doesn't need to make a living they can
move to the city and and do whatever
they're going to do there even though
we've been there for 150 years have you
considered owning nothing and being
happy I I have a hard time considering
that I just can't see all the work
there's some fluffy pods out there
though and you know video games VR
they're they're pretty cool maybe the
tortoise how about some bug program
here's compromise well take your whole
family we'll put them in pods we'll give
them VR headsets that simulate working
on a ranch out in Idaho and all the bugs
you could eat non-stop bugs yeah actual
exoskeletons right that they're that are
bad for us I don't know you know yeah
indigestible bug shelves so the feds
came in and were like by the way we've
owned this the whole time and you didn't
know kind of thing or what did they
offer compensation no not at all not at
all they no so yeah
they did do that which is an absolute
lie they they try to make the people of
this country believe that that has
always been in federal hands and that it
wasn't disposed of to the state and to
the people and it's just a flat lie well
really what what it was is the West is
just arid like there's you can't have
farms and you can't grow things in much
of the West and so people didn't settle
there and they just came in and said
look at all this land that no one's
living on no one's claimed we're going
to take it but the problem is is in the
west you don't claim the land you claim
like the grazing rights like my dad owns
the grazing rights the logging rights
the mining the mineral rights and those
were like deeded rights with the states
and so here the FED comes in feds come
in and say well we're taking the real
estate and therefore every anything else
that has rights on it we own we control
and it's this huge messed up legal
battle that's going on because my dad
has my dad has grazing rights he has 11
of them deeded with the state of Nevada
and then the federal government comes
along and says well we own the land we
own the so you can't graze here and he's
like wait a minute now that sounds bunk
because I've been we've been dealing
with with this when we were uh moving
out to West Virginia everybody warns you
you're only buying surface rights and
then I'm like what does that mean that
means that if somebody owns the mineral
rights they can come on your property in
a way that's reasonable and start
digging and then I'm like what what am I
buying then like if I'm gonna build
something here I can't if you come on
with some machinery and start digging in
my ground yeah so they they separated
that this was all part of this they
separated made it so that you can
separate the real estate the land with
the mineral rights right and that that
wasn't that wasn't always the case
remember the uh Beverly Hillbillies
where you bought this land and they were
digging and this oil comes out next
thing you know they you know they're
Millionaires and they moved to Beverly
Hills yeah well that's the way it used
to be like if you own the land you also
own the resources underneath it or above
it yup but now big corporations will buy
the land by the mineral rights sell the
surface to you and then in the event
they actually find something show up one
day and be like out of the way yep now
to our uh benefit I suppose there's not
really a whole lot going on in West
Virginia in terms of minerals so unless
they discover something they didn't know
about before some new minerals yeah
they're using all the coal gone man
because I thought West Virginia was all
about coal I think that's in the
mountains though like Mountaintop and
stuff like that I don't know for sure
what I do know is that when we were
looking at land we we went over this and
they were like you don't have mineral
rights but to be honest they've already
done a sweep here's the report there's
nothing here it's like mud and rock like
nothing worth anything but there's been
a new breakthrough in underground
scanning with I think lasers and there's
uh underground mapping yeah uh might not
be lidar but a form of laser underground
mapping so they might start finding
crazy minerals deeper than you thought I
don't know they could discover something
new that's what people don't realize we
may find out eventually that there's
something you know look we think we know
everything we think not literally but we
think we know and then one day it's like
oh hey wait a minute we need this kind
of mineral and it's not just this you
know graphene for instance well is that
an example yeah what if they just don't
want to mine the carbon they're like oh
now dirt itself is a mineral not that
what if they discover that there are
certain carbon deposits that are more uh
that can easily be converted into
graphene for some reason and now all of
a sudden they call it something like
graph carbon deposits and they say well
we didn't realize this 10 years ago and
we thought your property was worthless
but now fortunately we have the mineral
rights to your property and we found
there's graph carbon deposits so we're
coming on investors and they they can
take up to at least in the at least in
the west uh Nevada and they can take up
to 49 of your surface rights to to mine
or to extract whatever subsurface but
with you guys it was just about a
tortoise well yeah so like what so we're
like in the like the desert desert like
if there's a desert in this maybe the
Sahara Desert is a little bit drier but
that's about it I mean we're talking
about the Mojave Desert like no one
wanted to live there in fact
there was a group of people what are
they grazing on what are the cattle
grazing just like there's like there's
shrubs there's you know some there and
certain times of the year it it'll rain
and there will be grass
um you know they they have to struggle
from from yeah you know and then we have
these Waters because they're Springs so
we have Waters all around where they can
they're just little Springs but we
capture the water so they have water
troughs and they don't have to travel so
far
but that area was like 150 years ago no
one wanted it like the people that came
in before my family
they
they went back and reported to Brigham
Young and Salt Lake and said that the
place was uninhabitable right and then
we went in there a few years later and
started you know making a life out of it
and a living out of it and then now you
know for whatever reason well we know
why but uh they you know now now people
want it and uh was there like uranium or
something oh yeah I was going to show
you this uh I don't you know I don't
know if you but the real reason the real
reason is quite obvious of what what
they want and when you look at a at a
map of the federal control I'll just
show you for for the fun of it right you
all right with that oh is it is it is it
definitely minerals of some sort so this
right here is
that's a map of of the the red is
federal controlled land yeah so you can
see the West is like they own Nevada
yeah they've yeah 89 but then what do
they want with the land well this is
this is the whole point so let's look at
uh these are the Mercury and gold mines
yeah here we go it's the same map wow
right right and and and like uh here's a
uranium
exactly it's the same Mac called it and
that's what that's what they want
they're they're controlling the natural
resources and they want to make people
think that they're doing it to preserve
it why don't they just come to you guys
and be like here's 10 million dollars
have a nice day because they didn't
think they had to they thought that they
could come in and just take it because
they've done it to to hundreds and
hundreds of other ranchers and and
loggers and Miners and everything else I
mean look they just print the money
anyway they should just walk up and be
like here's 10 million bucks what if
they do it to us you know then they have
to do it to everybody else and they
found a better way they they just run
you out apparently not now I mean at the
very least they should have they haven't
come to you since then and been like
okay how much do you want actually uh
they they tried that with my dad but
they so the the the Constitution which I
know they don't follow it
but but they actually did they tried to
get the county to buy my dad's rights
and my dad refused he didn't want to
sell them right and so and and and I'll
say this though but they try they can't
even offered a a good enough no they
offered him seventy five thousand
dollars right right so which is you know
the price of a pickup right now so yeah
exactly yeah your family's history
everything your legacy your your farm
it's gone here 75k it's like but but it
was in the attitude well we're gonna
take it anyway so here this is an easy
way out for you and wow my dad is act
absolutely no so what if they came and
said two million dollars would you guys
pack up no so no no my my dad has been
offered for because he has a lot of
water rights like actual coming down the
river too and uh and private private
property there
and so he's been offered a decent amount
of you know millions of dollars and he's
just not he doesn't want to sell I mean
for whatever reason he has his reasons
he's not going to sell has he considered
taking like hundreds of thousands of
balloons and putting him in his chimney
and then flying the house away and try
to take the property I saw a story about
that once that's crazy it's crazy what
what's going on what happened what was
the resolution I heard that the ranch
like The Story Goes you guys were like
no we're not giving it they came on the
property there's a shootout so
uh there wasn't a shootout but what
ultimately what happened this was during
Obama uh 2014 and he thought he had
enough political power and and he had a
basically an internal internal
bureaucratic Army and he sent that them
down upon my family
um it was the FBI which we didn't know
that at first but FBI Bureau of Land
Management U.S forest Service that's BLM
yeah yeah the other Bureau of Land
before it was cool and they came down
with a 213 Federal armed basically Army
and locked the ranch down
uh they began to kill the cattle from
from helicopters burying them in Mass
Graves destroyed the water
infrastructure destroy the corels and
meanwhile they were threatening that
this would be another Waco or Ruby Ridge
if we were resisted yeah so we it took
us a while to gain enough courage to
start to like confront them and stand up
to them and people started coming and
then they they killed your animals yeah
they killed like 60 head and buried them
in Mass with a helicopter shooting them
with helicopters yeah I mean this all
sounds like explicitly illegal like
they're committing crimes yeah but
that's the definition of government yeah
but no
but they also claimed you know they were
saying we were trespassing yeah but I
don't think like if if someone's cow
wanted on my property I can't kill it
yeah I don't I mean like the federal
government does what they want to do
yeah all right right they do what they
want to do if it was a bull maybe and
like went on my land and like playing
something yeah there's like a cow you
know a couple of cow walking by I think
it's no one no no one would find it
reasonable that you started mowing them
down from a helicopter yeah be like yo
dude what are you doing I agree I mean
no look right now we got the story with
Lauren bobert where the Democrats
accused her of killing a dog and then
like you read for 10 seconds into the
story and you're like oh the dog broke
onto her property it was attacking her
goats then you read it's actually her
other neighbor who killed the dog
because the dog had actually attacked a
bunch of animals and Lauren's like I had
nothing to do with this talk about
defamation right yeah seriously but I
mean in in in that capacity it's like
you know you've got something attacking
your animals you protect your property
to protect your animals absolutely but
that's what not what was going no this
is
they were just killing them burying them
in Mass Graves causing Mayhem literally
and then we started so the interesting
thing is is that they
they set up these areas that they called
First Amendment areas they were like
miles away from the ranch and they were
like these construction mesh you know
the orange construction masks Freedom
cages yeah and they and they said that
if you're going to protest or
demonstrate or anything our actions you
have to do it in there that's your first
amendment area so of course we didn't do
that so they started sicking dogs on us
and tasing us and throwing us to the
ground and doing all this stuff well
people were filming it and they started
sending it all over the country and next
thing you know we got hundreds and then
thousands of people coming you know what
this story reminds me of
Avatar you guys know that that movie
yeah yeah where where the noble true
land owners are minding their own
business on their big tree and the evil
government comes in to steal all those
minerals beneath that tree just killing
everybody that's right yeah yeah that's
the story here the only thing is it
doesn't really work towards their
Hollywood narrative because it's a bunch
of like white ranchers I guess and not
Native Americans yeah that's why we
weren't so popular right uh because we
were just there and evidence colonizers
yeah
well and I I do say this all the time
like I know when I was born there there
was no Native Americans other than other
ranchers there was other ranchers that
were actually Native Americans that
ranched in their Rancier and they were
they were pushed out and driven out just
like the rest of us yeah well that's
another story about the the colonial
patriarchy government kicking out you
know the honest worker right that's
right yeah it's not it's not a racist
system it's just hungry for money and
resources power and there there's this
um
like
Unholy alliance between those who want
to control the resources make money and
all of that build their bureaucracies
all that power stuff that we know about
and these globalist environmentalists
the green religion and they've like
locked arms in basically coming and
trying to control and drive mankind off
off the land that's oh that's very uh
telling and I think that correlates with
what you're saying about going after the
standards for the tortoise yeah that's
exactly that's that's why so you've got
you know this the global
environmentalists that are like saying
we got to save the tortoise which it's
all based upon lies and then you have
the those who want to control the the
resources the the subsurface mineral
rights and the land and so forth saying
like well come come with us and we'll
will stop people from using this and
then then they take it for themselves
and that's that's what's been happening
all over the West is it like a tortoise
Haven or something you guys got a lot of
them well
I mean there's there's a lot of there's
a decent amount of desert tortoise down
there but the thing thing of it is is
the studies actually the true studies
actually showed that when there's cattle
there there was more desert tortoise
because the their main staple was manure
right they actually ate the turtles ate
them oh yeah they dig through it yeah
the the cow pies a big they'd go in it
and they would dig it and they they
would Thrive off of it so when you had
more cattle uh you had more desert
tortoise but they didn't care about that
they don't care about them I was going
to say that because
um it seems to me that cattle coming in
it's going to create it's going to
expand the ecosystem that the manure is
going to result in more growth it's
going to it's going to deposit you know
minerals or whatever and then just
result in it in a more robust ecosystem
albeit still small and desert-like but
but Tim I just want to I just want to
talk about this fact here the US
government literally tested 1032 nuclear
weapons on American soil this is a
government that does not care about any
kind of natural environment or anything
that the U.S military industrial complex
the U.S war machine is one of the
biggest polluters by definition and and
of course that's just being uh
by the way but why did why why did they
test those nuclear weapons to protect
the tortoise all right they knew that
Vladimir Putin you know Khrushchev and
Lennon and all those guys going way back
what they were really after the Soviets
they needed to tourists they needed to
Nuke the turtles
in my opinion the federal government
owns 28 of all land in the United States
that is 28 too much in my own personal
opinion and those Free Speech zones are
absolutely absurd and I think they were
ruled unconstitutional they were
originally started by George W Bush when
he was trying to stop a protest against
his regime and and his larger anti-war
protests that of course people were
protesting against and they just were
like well you can't really protest but
you can in our little regulated areas
where of course you don't have any
speech at all you're just you're just
cattle yourself which is absolutely
crazy thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there